ce que je peux vous renseigner eh bien
je suis intéressé par le miel coraline
sa lieu est apicultrice depuis cinq ans
originaire de l'île de ré c'est à
cour-cheverny qu'elle a trouvé sa terre
d'adoption et sa corne d'abondance
ont produit phare ça va être le miel
bien de ma production je vais je vais
prendre bien sûr que ce que je produis
en plus grande quantité donc c'est à
dire le miel de printemps le fleur et le
fleur d'été parce que par exemple pour
l'acacia fait qu'une toute petite
production donc je peux me permettre de
le proposer un salon pas comme comme le
salon de l'agriculture
dans sa boutique de 30 mètres carrés pas
moins de 3 à 400 produits certains
viennent de producteurs locaux ici le
bouche à oreille a vite fait une
réputation
ça change de ce qu'on peut goûter
habituellement parce que là en fait sont
des produits qui sont à la fois de bonne
qualité et qui ont vraiment du groupe
qu'en plus les locales donc ça là tous
les avantages le salon de l'agriculture
sera une première pour cette jeune femme
de 29 ans une vitrine à marche-pied son
galop d'essai c'est vrai que j'ai jamais
fait donc je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
vraiment à quoi m'attendre j'ai juste
envie de faire des belles rencontres
de trouver d'éventuellement des nouveaux
clients bats pour mon miel des petites
épiceries sympa à paris qui
souhaiteraient éventuellement accueillir
du 1er français et peut-être l'année
prochaine d'attenté tenter ma chance
parce que c'est quand même sympa d'avoir
une reconnaissance sur son travail et je
trouve que c'est une bonne médaille à
l'extérieur du magasin des ruches en
bois pédagogique bon an mal an des 170 à
200 ruches de cette apicultrice lui
procure 3 à 5 tonnes de mil le plus
difficile à produire je dirais que ici
dans la région c'est miel d'acacia car
l'effort d'acacia sont très fragiles
donc il suffit qu'il pleuve qu'une
petite tempête un peu devant toute forme
acacias d'un petit nième d'acacias pour
ceux qui concourent le salon de
l'agriculture est un pari est un risque
financier
subventionné à 60 %
par la région centre